[Music]
welcome to a very special edition of
good morning buckle up I am your host
Stephen credit or audio Wade is here
with me yes happy to be here today
perhaps one of the most controversial
installments as you see the toilet paper
sort of champagne tower if you will in
the studio right now very soon
Betty Crowder Doug Oh Argentina was very
much a an unhealthy pension for toilet
paper who will enter into the studio
live in an absolutely Rama gent we
believe of course the hashtag is mug
Club quarantine where you are getting
more content than ever before
all right incredibly grateful to the
team here in the promo promotional code
is is quarantine where you will get $30
off right and as we go into this some
folks may be shocked by what they see
here yes and I certainly understand I
understand the disturbing nature of this
but Stephen why why do this today why
why during this time we've certainly
here at the Leno's credit program some
could argue if and more boombastic
programming before unconfrontational but
nothing as controversial with gross
disregard for the needy in the face of a
toilet paper shortage but for those who
don't entirely understand I'm reminded
of the story of the starfish the young
boy who saved a starfish and there were
thousands washing a pup up upon the
scene a man said why don't you throw
that one starfish back into the ocean
they're all there are thousands of other
starfish right he said but I could save
that one starfish Wow
I know the many people out there are
clamoring for for toilet paper and
forced to use them unflushable wet wipes
right now which is caused a great
problem for the septic tank industry but
we can't help all of those people but we
can provide one day of bliss and Miller
young dog Oh puppy yes and many don't
know that that young boy was you it's
true yes dr genetic profiling that
identifies a an IBD gene which is
different from IB IBS and then IBD is is
far more severe I'm getting word that
Betty Crowder is going to be leaving the
dog pen soon getting ready
to send her and and very curious as to
how she approaches oh there she is right
now she's checking seem to be check
she's checking it was it was a question
if there we go right away I grabbed a
single roll of toilet paper that's when
I suspected understanding sort of the
breed standard yeah she's never been
faced with this much toilet paper in
front of her she usually has to sneak a
roll of course from the bathroom or
sometimes from the linen closet which is
where a little inside baseball here
that's when we keep our toilet paper we
we don't just call it the linen closet
at the crowded household we call it the
linen and your toilet paper closet so
it's very curious as to how she would
react when faced with an entire note you
see this right here how she ISM she's
pawing at the toilet paper she's
separated from the pack right it's been
acute it is it seems very cute to the
untrained eye sort of say the paws on
there underneath her chin or sort of
like via the Sears catalog family photo
you might send out in a Christmas car
Serena of course in her mind she's
absolutely murdering senselessly that
roll of toilet paper like a baby
mountain lion cub Wow because that is of
course the history of the breed that's
what they were to do yes and Betty is a
as you said a dog Oh Argentina that's
correct yes and you mentioned the breed
history tell us a little bit about that
oh wow look she's really if you can see
this applying torque look at the way
she's using her neck and had really in a
in a twisting motion um just shredding
that toilet paper and that's something
that's actually very characteristic of
the dog Oh Argentina breed you know it
always bothers me now that it sort of
becomes slang to refer to dogs as dog
O's you'll see on Instagram people are
saying good dog oh it's Dogo Argentino
dog Oh doesn't mean anything a lot of
people think that that's translated from
the Spanish pronunciation of dog and
that's entirely incorrect right that's
not at all right that is a persistent
myth yeah however I'm not entirely aware
of the pronunciation of Dogo in Spanish
but in French it is shame and I would
believe considering that they all
originated the Romance languages from
Latin would probably be more similar to
that now look at this she's she's really
peeling off layers here which shows a
great magnitude of control because that
toilet paper only exists
really for as long as she allows it hmm
so she is powerful but merciful and
since there's certainly an intense
amount of focus yes I I was absolutely
at some level expecting her to approach
the entire pyramid at once but she does
seem to have honed in on this particular
role yes
is this common for for Betty's in
particular and for Doug Arnett she knows
in general that's and that's an
excellent question and it's a it is
doggo argentino event they're not out
there wearing a pleated pants it's not a
Chino
that's quite in the j.crew catalog I
apologize I like to have a laugh oh one
moment see she she just she just sort of
stood up and torqued it - that's what we
call the deathblow here chuckle
argentinos were bred from a long lineage
of hunting look at that oh wow look at
that torque just imagine that if that
were a boar
or a cougar which is what they were bred
to hunt Doug argentinos a lot of people
think that they're large
pit bulls but they actually don't share
any of the same lineage of course both
on the bully breed territory but Doug
goes hunt in packs and they would
seclude for example a boar or a mountain
lion away from the rest of their
brothers and sisters pin them and slowly
just just tear the life from oh and now
she's look at this
well well she seems to be approaching
more toilet paper you know much like a
pyramid of avocados at a grocery store
yes very similar esting one by one and
look you know what she that's that's a
remarkable understanding of efficiency
because rather than chase the rolls that
are falling and wasting energy she is
simply don't you understand that there
are more rolls and right now she's
simply deciding almost like Jenga which
role would be the easiest for her to
take out in a weakened state well and
exploit I can't quite see you know
wonderful another angle yeah the
persistence and the patience really is
worthy of note a remarkable breed a
remarkable breed you know they're a
breed that are not for a first time dog
owner because you know if you have a
golden retriever even you know perhaps a
cocker spaniel and
know how to train a dog they get out of
line at at best it's insufferable at
worst it's someone cute with a dog oh
they will take your life
why no questions asked Wow absolutely
and Betty in particular has shown an
affinity for toilet paper when did you
first notice Betty's
love for toilet paper you know it was
very interesting where we were advised
to punish Betty when she would take food
from the table with a rolled-up paper
towel roll and not so much of course for
people out there not to to harm her in
any way but that sound though her advice
would scare them kind of like a very
similar to a rolled-up newspaper roll
and instead she um she actually swiped
it from my hand and began devouring it
which we thought was at the time amusing
but looking back we absolutely should
not have laughed because we really
created an in graham in her work she
believed that to be appropriate behavior
and we created a monster
there's I have to say that living with a
Doug origin Tino like Betty with an
affinity for toilet paper
during the corona virus pandemic is it's
very similar to not of course to make
light of those who've suffered at the
Holocaust but being a Jewish individual
in an attic with a baby who won't stop
crying hmm with the SS on the main floor
below you guys quite similar I don't
think that's making a lot of it at all I
don't think so well I it's a comparison
that I think is is necessary during
these hard time after certainly yes and
I noticed the Betty does have a patch of
loose skin on the back of her head and
correct yes is that characteristic of of
all Doug or argentinos or Betty in
particular yes yes for many people
asking this question again these dogs
are bred as hunting dogs and protectors
at the farm in an Argentina also a
little known fact the most hated country
in South America though some argue it's
a little bit of jealousy there kind of
like Canada with the United States their
host over there they certainly are are
wealthier on a financial level and their
women are more attractive better soccer
players as well but yes they have bred
these dogs to hunt bore and cougar and
the reason for that lose skin those
folds in the back of the neck
reminiscent of a shar-pei but without
the you know the the unstoppable
never-ending yeast infections is if a if
a cougar amount
herb or should grab Betty by the neck
she can still wrap around almost like a
hip out in that perhaps greco-roman
wrestling and pin the the wild animal by
the neck and that's a big difference
between them and for example German
Shepherds are our Dobermans in that they
pin and hold the kill they're the animal
until the owner comes and ceremoniously
and the traditional fashion kills it
with a knife and lets head bleed out and
as we look here we do see Betty
continuing to go one by one through
these rolls of paper again we see a and
that's a surprise to me is it it is I
was I was a little apprehensive in
broadcasting that's because I thought
well we're doing this live and there's a
strong chance that she simply bulldoze
us through the toilet paper rolls like
the the gentleman the Ambassador
previously for up for for kool-aid the
beverage is but instead she seems to be
very strategic and now she's approaching
this bordering on cautious yeah I really
do miss that advertising campaign it was
a very effective advertising campaign
also a very fear-inspiring inspiring
people will talk about that enough they
don't it was a very and I don't know
exactly where Betty has left the toilet
paper has she become uninterested in the
I don't know if she's become
uninterested that would seem out of
character for her considering just how
much she finds herself magnetically
drawn to toilet paper at this point and
there's just plenty of toilet paper
alone she does seem to be approaching
the door that is interesting and of
course we have for those who are worried
we have locked her in she did go potty
before this broadcast yes and she will
not be let out until she's finished her
toilet paper it's it's so similar to the
equivalent of a father finding a son
with them you know a Marlboro and then
forcing him to smoke the rest of the
pack of cigarettes she and again she has
approach inducing nicotine poisoning yes
she has approached the collection cos
and rejected that one she yeah
apparently there must be something wrong
you know and of course the quality
control can't be as stringent as as
usual when you have a shortage during
these times we do have a mixture here of
single and double ply we've several
different brands and Alfred
but we believe that it would be
environmentally unsound to exclusively
use to apply and and I understand that
some of our viewers may have some health
concerns about about Betty's eating that
is correct
yeah some people's matter of fact we are
seeing some tweets right now a gentleman
by the name of Reginald right now is
saying that this is very [ __ ] up that
is very [ __ ] up he said well everyone
is entitled to their opinion and I'm not
it it is not entirely with disagreement
from from us here but of course
individually from our listeners we do
enjoy hearing from our listeners the
promotional code is Florentine $30
dollar and now she seems to be taking a
break
mmm Betty which ism you just see the
muscle on the back of those thighs you
just say what a powerful animal it is
impressively
very similar to a mountain lion how so
um well I just meet him the in effect of
this lean long muscle bellies and almost
like a swimmer um many of course is 92
pounds and she was anticipated to be
much larger she was a pick of the litter
but that would be actually rather grunty
for a a Doug of argentino because she
did have a health scare when she was
young along as a reaction to anesthetic
and um well we considered actually not
reviving her but that was a primarily
due to cost concerns certainly well 92
pounds do you think that this is an
advantage or a disadvantage in this
scenario that's a very good question
knowing a thing cuz you do have to
balance um and you'll see this with with
a sort of packs of taco argentinos can
go out on a wild boar hunt typically if
they need to roam longer distances
they'll send out the smaller dongho's it
is a balance of endurance and power and
at around that 92 pound mark she would
be right in the middle of the pack sort
of a Doug of all trades if you will Wow
and um very very powerful animals really
agile she seems to have found something
toward the center of the pile right
maybe an especially delicious for all
well well I think we've all been guilty
of that time or two especially around
Thanksgiving you know many people ask
actually um are they intelligent dogs
and the answer to that is unequivocally
no very much not the case with Doug Howe
argentinos
highly unintelligent and I found them
incredibly easy to trick mmm
they have no sense of space or time if
you for example pretend that you are
throwing a ball but you know you Oh what
do you have behind your back there they
don't know the difference Wow if if the
dog Oh were a Cuomo brother which would
it be well that's a very difficult
question to answer of course because
they're they're all on variant
tragically functionally [ __ ] right
and fortunately in Betty's case she's
she's right at the middle of the bell
curve for Doug argentinos not at the
bottom quite like the Cuomo family but
they're still quite um still quite
challenged in the news that could be an
unfair comparison in apologies do you
see how this is actually she's stringing
it out here I believe she's she's now
she's looking for a chase this has been
too easy so she wants to watch the
toilet paper unravel these these dogs
they don't know they don't really want
to attack dead animals hmm they are bred
for hunting and holding and then
instinct of an animal shaking beneath
their grasp actually only encourages
them to grip more tightly well but when
that toilet paper roll is is just
sitting there um you know flaccid though
they've just had a cup of coffee with
perhaps um the late Bill Cosby or I
guess not the link but soon to be um
it's it's very uninteresting mmm so this
this pile of toilet paper is somewhat
like a pile of dead raccoons she seems
to maybe be approaching it a little more
slowly than if there's risk involved and
really what you what you want to do with
these dogs if you want them to be more
lively is to encourage their prey
instincts okay
if you run they will chase if that
toilet paper roll glides across the
floor like a streamer she's far more
likely to be active and of course also
people who are noticing right now Betty
since our health care hasn't have
normally large anus over duck or
Argentina which is um problematic when
it comes to uh obviously no one wants to
one of the perks of having me a canine
friend is not having to wipe that's very
similar to running over time right
without extra pay
sting effect to about Betty she perhaps
gets this there's a famous dango
argentino if you run a youtube search
called remote Roadshow who protected two
children on an argentinian farm from a
mountain lion
they found the children in a tree
Morocho missing about half of her face
or orbital bone in a dead mountain lion
she was willing to serve her life to
protect those children and betty is a
direct descendant i believe a great
granddaughter of Morocho and of course
has none of those instincts as i have a
no doubt that if i was chased down on my
home drive with a Yorkie she would leave
me for dead interesting nonetheless yes
yes very much so and again we're from a
promotional code is quarantine $30 off
there's good morning among club this
obviously cost us a small fortune we are
seeing now from one mr. John in
Massapequa New York who has tweeted you
for this seriously I hope you die hmm
and just repeats the first portion of
that I don't think it's necessary Wow
yeah so it seems as though people are
relatively upset with this which we are
certainly really negative yes I'd have
probably I have I haven't heard accounts
of people having to take showers after
each time they use the restroom as which
again is sad yeah so and that's set for
us as Americans but if you think about
that the French do that all the time
they call it a day but um they're not
fooling anybody I never thought of up a
day is a tiny little shower of course
and in Middle Eastern cultures they we
all know they simply prefer to use their
hand hmm so if you manage to get
yourself in a meeting with Qaddafi
you're effectively squeezing the Charmin
of course not in these days of social
distancing in which case you you the new
approach is bumping elbows after you've
coughed into it well lay doors on end we
don't want to pay paint the Middle East
in broad brushes of course well I I
would understand why one might feel that
way but I entirely am said that with
with great purpose maybe we should get
back to they do have also also not big
not big supporters of dogs there
and they see them as as very dirty
animals you know we see them as our
companions of course because look at the
torque and that move right there look at
that work its artistry which by the way
interesting fact about tacos the bite
pressure which is measured in psi pounds
per square inch as a matter of fact with
a golden retriever somewhere around 200
pounds or standard Labrador and I
believe that a pit bull of Staffordshire
or American Pit Bull Terrier and German
shepherds register around 300 something
psi the dug origin Tino clocks in at a
whopping 515 pressure well just imagine
if she was granted just imagine if you
were one of these rolls of toilet paper
right hmm it'd be an agonizing mechanism
and uh there by pressure I believe is
second only to two other dogs the
Caucasian of our chica and the Kangol
which of course have a bite pressure of
700 pounds per square inch but not very
great human family compete Caucasian of
varsha also very bad at jumping yes they
are very much slow twitch muscle fibers
it is a it's a grind where they can
apply that pressure but gradually of
course not not to be confused with that
for example of a Rottweiler where they
can apply it very quickly certainly do
the fast twitch fibers it's a little bit
of you know
Betty's older brother the late and great
hopper was very friendly as you know
what other dogs but does not get along
very well with this one Rottweiler down
the block in it it was very reminiscent
of the old mand comedy magazines spy
versus spy well as always how I how I
described at spy versus spy or of course
that dumb that's a one famous scene from
American History X but it was just an
interesting interesting dynamic I miss
magazines I do as well well certainly I
was just noticing that betty is moving
away from the pyramid mm-hmm so not not
quite a pyramid anymore Oh dolly
I'd say really more of a of a of a bog
of eternal Tyler at this point Reverend
the Egyptian masters would not be happy
about this they would not be happy about
this at all if they were planning on
being embalmed they would be sorely
disappointed no of course we just they
didn't use to own the paper they used
some form of organic cloth with which we
believe to be cotton but we know no one
knows for sure hmm and this is
interesting it almost acts her coat is a
natural camouflage when surrounded by
toilet paper I don't know about you but
at this point I'm having a difficult
time identifying and this is an adaptive
this is an adaptive mechanism of course
you know that's incorrect not at all she
said not at all and as a matter of fact
they don't even know they don't even
live in cold climates where snow would
be present so if anything it would be a
net devolvement for the species but it
is beautiful it is always a sight to
behold Steve Jobs misses the sort of dog
that Steve Jobs would have if he hadn't
put himself in a shallow grave with a
fruitarian diet yes shunned Western
medicine
yes but he was a great minimalist of
course he of course was yeah it looks
like Betty is moving behind the desk I
don't I don't believe there's any toilet
paper there don't believe there is and
looks like all been caught our attention
there on the raw chair oh that's
interesting it look oh something
startled her there Wow
not entirely sure what that could be the
chair seems to have moved on expect it
does seem that that keep in mind that is
the chair where even Brendon was sitting
only several days ago and there could be
of course a well know a foul or odor
emitting so which generally dogs would
find pleasant but tell me this might
just be too overpowering and if anyone
is nervous about betty approaching the
chair where even Brendon sat dogs cannot
get the kovat 19 that's what we believe
iris Hills just the recent transfer to
Tigers so we are hoping that the
transmission of from humans to animals
as limited only to
exotic highly prized well I hope the
audience will forgive me I was operating
on old information oh and she is polling
at look at whoa look at that it's very
interesting because see she has fully
intact toilet paper rolls but like I
said it's that it's that prey instinct
there's an interest in movement right
I'm very much like a t-rex mm-hmm
a Tyrannosaurus Rex where she only takes
if you don't move you're probably safer
also yes go ahead I'm just going to ask
this this tidbit about t-rex's of
courses is Tyrannosaurus Rex yes
speculation
I'm sorry if we have if we have Beckett
backing up information that that is
correct um but we know firm as a matter
of fact we know that that is incorrect
which really should surprise nobody
considering that they were they were
making a great determinations from
fossil records to determine the efficacy
of the vision the Tyrannosaurus Rex is
it should surprise no one that that of
course was was pseudoscience and T Rex's
can see you if you if you were to stay
still with a t-rex they would I'd you
would simply be a dead dead t-rex and
Michael Crichton resident power of
course yes absolutely mr. Michael
Crichton brilliant bro almost almost an
Oracle Michael Crichton and I wonder
what he would say if he could be here
today to watch this spectacle before us
no doubt he'd be impressed certainly
well and she is approaching the
toilet-paper
pyramid again yeah seems to have slowed
her pace she does seem to have slowed
her pace and you have to ask yourself if
that's a byproduct of exhaustion you
know as with any other athletic endeavor
lactic acid buildup right or if she
simply can can no longer breathe as
she's blocked her air passageways with
the toilet paper which upon reflection
was a very irresponsible endeavor for us
to undertake particularly for an entire
um half I'm one of brokenly what we can
hope that that is not the case we can
certainly hope that that is not the case
though she there is key dog insurance
taken out on Betty Crowder as she is of
course the spokesperson very popular for
Walter Firearms
and that's really because dogs can't
drink coffee so black rifle gave uh gave
a call to Alana's Crowder studios and
said could Betty do some live reads and
I said well I don't know how much you're
aware but a coffee is a very potent
neurotoxin for dogs certainly I'll be a
short-lived commercial iSeries and it
looks as the hood of dark humor that's
like yes we do like if because if you
don't laugh you'll cry if you don't
laugh you'll try much as of course we
would if she were to ingest significant
amounts of the neurotoxin that which is
known as caffeine also Phil bromine and
chocolate I believe that is she has left
she's a pet no she's there under the
camera oh look at that
mica just when we thought she was good
just when you thought it was safe to go
back in the studio
it's Betty - oh dear oh dear yeah so she
looks like she has approached a role
that was sitting on the couch very
clever - um sort of an Easter egg hunt
to place them at different locations
throughout the studio but she does seem
at this point as though she's she is
ready to leave the studio how is that
does that mean that she is uh are we uh
are we close to her leaving I can't see
her anyway
I'm not sure I think we may send someone
in to throw another roll of toilet paper
just to see okay oh there she is back
never mind looks well he has oh well
sort of a little bit of an escape from
alcatraz there where she knows sort of
just where to stand so that we can't
keep our eye on an old Betty there a
classic film it isn't yes it is a
classic of course which was entirely
entirely a copied or an plagiarized in
the Shawshank Redemption yes many people
don't know that though it was a less
racist version of the instalment more
palatable to the American public again
we have a tweet right now actually also
on a live chat someone saying that this
live chat sucks and would you hear you
um and we do have an issue with the live
chat available at plays TV able to do
you cannot enter in your username at the
moment
um but I don't know that it's kind of
codes but if you if you include your
name in the message we will be able to
to read it up right we will be certain
to him immediately not get back to you
that's true
certainly oh look at that right there
she's found a barrier okay that's
another read share she seems to be
attracted to the red chairs which of
course in nature a bright colors like
that are our signals of danger well for
example we've all seen the crab that
puts up its claws and underneath to
reveal a red under claw and that's to
say hey buddy you you can try and take a
take a gobble here if you like but I
don't think you'll you'll enjoy how this
ends up nature is fun it is fun in his
fun and scary frightening at frightening
at a visceral level it is we just
realize how horribly equipped human
beings are oh ah there we go
ah yes looks like someone was throwing a
curve ball into the mix one more roll of
toilet paper to see what's the effect if
that Chase instinct kicks in oh there
she goes a little more cautious than I
believed that he would be um and
certainly more so than I hope she would
be considering the incredible amount
that was spent due to the price gouging
hmm and we apologize anybody in the
Austin area or four surrounding ZIP
codes will not be able to procure any
toilet paper for the next four weeks due
to this broadcast but we feel it was of
course for a worthy cause and it seems
she is approaching the the role that was
thrown in is it's hard for me to tell
again because yes they are also similar
they are similar and and again she does
blend in and she is as I said earlier
adapted to live in twelve paper-like
climates this is true did you have any
sort of leaning did you believe she
would favor the single or the multi ply
goodness I I for one did think so
sometimes when toilet paper rolls are
thicker there they're labeled as being
two rolls the larger rolls I assumed she
would go for the larger rolls but again
it's very hard to tell which of these
rolls she's going that's true and oh
she's returning to that chair
and Brennan was sitting at see that
chair is is drop tested to 500 pounds it
is an industrial furniture but at this
point has been sitting largely unused
due to guests on skype so that is really
just a trapping of of lint in even
Brendan's pain killer farts that's right
after his most recent knee surgery of
course so there must be something about
the combination there that um it's more
interesting to and dogs are of course
colorblind so this this chair very well
might look like a large green chair
that's incorrect yeah dogs are not
colorblind we used to be under that
impression but as a matter of fact we
found out that was a myth when Winston
Churchill crumpled up a packet of
cigarettes and it was a packet of I
believe Newports the red packet of
cigarettes threw it into ace into a
fireplace and it resembled is of course
famous British bulldogs favorite red
ball which prompted his dog to throw
himself into the fireplace and and died
not immediately but later on of
third-degree burns how interesting well
many know that every time an election
year comes around that a dog is sent to
eat from One Bowl or another that
represents one candidate or a different
one
we are we doing something similar with
this oh is it is it an election time
again yeah well I almost forgot it seems
almost all anyone can talk about these
days of course that was a little sarcasm
there I would say this is I did have
trouble with that yes I apologize
sometimes that's it's a little dry the
way that I approach humor but but I
would say it's more comparable to the
way that we ring in the new year whereas
of course you know that we have an older
gentleman engage in physical feats of
strength with a baby to see who what
really if we are going to have four more
weeks of 2019
and so I I'm not entirely sure where the
analogy started but it really it came
from a good place and um me entered a
little bit but I would say that's an apt
well it looks like Betty has become
totally uninterested as she learned the
toilet paper so I yeah it looks like
she's left it looks like we can
officially count that time there I
believe the clunk means I don't have it
in for me about thirty two minutes well
that was absolutely um captivating a
thrilling installment of live broadcast
and I think that we should probably be
doing this every Wednesday for good
morning mud closer look we appreciate
everyone who joined us engaged with your
chats and your tweets of course do tune
in Friday morning in this evening more
programming than ever Atlanta with
CARICOM /schedule and use the
promotional code quarantine for $30 off
as we appreciate the support it's
required and most importantly if you
don't we will place of course Betty
Crowder in a closet and beater for days
without mercy so that's not an empty
threat please eat my words take them
seriously thank you
[Music]